-Our next guest
is a Pulitzer Prize-winning
and Tony-nominated playwright
whose critically acclaimed
new musical "A Strange Loop"
is currently on Broadway
at the Lyceum Theater.
Fresh off the musical's
11 Tony nominations,
please welcome to the show,
Michael R. Jackson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you, Michael?
-I'm doing pretty great, Seth.
-You've already won a Pulitzer.
You are now nominated
11 times for the Tony Award.
Is it sinking in exactly
how people have responded
to your show?
-It's sinking.
I don't know if
it's quite gotten there yet,
but it's there.
-It is really, really exciting.
And I think one of the things
that's coolest about this show
is when people comment on it,
they stress how unique it is.
Were you setting out to make
a show that was unique,
compared to what we tend
to find on Broadway?
-I mean, when I first set out
to work on this show,
I was 23 years old.
I was just writing, like,
a sort of life raft for myself.
So I don't -- and I definitely
wanted it to be,
you know, specific
and and nuanced and complex,
but I had no real thoughts
about what anybody else
would think about it.
-So did that put less pressure
on you, because you weren't
setting out to, you know,
make this thing that would
take the world by storm?
-Yeah, because like back then,
no one cared who I was.
[ Laughter ] Like, at all.
So I was like,
I'll just do whatever I want.
-And you've referred to it
as not autobiographical,
but self-referential.
What is the distinction there?
-For me, autobiography
sort of suggests
that there's a 1-to-1 ratio
of events to my life,
and I would say it's more
emotionally autobiographical.
I felt everything that
the protagonist feels,
but we have
different life experiences
and the details are different.
-So it is about an usher
named Usher?
-Mm-hmm.
-You were a Broadway usher.
-I was, indeed.
-Do you feel like
that was a skill,
or an experience, I should say,
that made you more skilled
in trying to write
a musical like this?
-Yes, because I didn't
want to usher anymore,
so I needed to write
something that could, like,
propel me out of that life.
-Yeah, but would you --
I mean, did you get a chance
to see
show after show after show?
-Oh, I saw more
than show after show after show.
I mean, I was like
constantly at the back,
you know, at the back
of the house of "The Lion King"
night after night,
watching the animals,
watching the animals.
Watching, you know,
the people down the aisles.
-Usher in the show names names.
There are some real people
that are commented on.
-For sure.
-Did you think
in the writing, ever,
"Oh, I might have to
take this out one day if --"
-I did, and then, like --
there was this one draft
where I think I changed
the name to like,
"Skyler Terry."
And I was like,
and then my director was like,
"Get the hell out of here.
You're not doing that."
So we left it the same.
And then ever since then, I felt
like I had full permission.
-That's very nice.
So the song tonight
is called "Inner White Girl."
And so, again, this is
self-referential.
This is something
that is true of you.
Can you speak a little bit
about what this song is about?
-Yeah, I sort of
as a teenager, was like,
as angsty as you could get.
And I was like, just coming out
and, like, feeling,
you know, sad and emo
all the time.
And of course, into Tori Amos
via my cousin who, like,
gave me her first two albums,
"Little Earthquakes"
and "Under the Pink."
And I sort of one night
turned all the lights off,
put my headphones on,
get under the covers,
and then Tori Amos
starts singing to me,
and I was a goner.
[ Laughter ]
-We were also talking
backstage about
our shared love affair
for Liz Phair as well.
-Yeah, Liz Phair
was in my twenties,
when I was just feeling,
like, even more emo,
but a little more
punk rock about it.
-Yeah.
-And, like, wandering around
New York City,
just like, hating everything
in my life and everyone.
And Liz is really
good music to have for you,
for that and on that.
-Yeah, I agree.
I think she's
the closest thing I have
to an inner white girl,
is Liz Phair.
That is the most I've
listened to on headphones.
I feel like she makes you
feel very cool
for hating everything.
-She does, because she has
such a, like,
a really badass sense of humor
and a lot of candor
as she sort of speaks
about her experiences
through the characters
in her songs.
-This is also very exciting.
It's no Pulitzer, mind you,
but you saw Tori Amos
in concert last night.
-Yes.
-Tonight you
are going again, backstage.
You're going to meet her
for the first time.
-I'm gonna meet her tonight.
-How do you think
it's going to go?
What are you worried about
or excited about?
-I'm worried that I might,
you know, cry all over...
[ Laughter ]
...like, everything
that she's wearing
and make a complete
imbecile of myself.
-What are her expectations?
Is she aware of what a big part
of the show she is
and a big part of your story?
-I don't think so.
I think I've kept
that pretty close to the vest,
because then she might not
let me come back and see her.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, after the success
of the show,
it must be so exciting.
It was this Monday when you find
out about all the nominations.
Like, do you now have --
what is your anticipation
leading up to the Tonys?
Is it mostly just excitement?
Do you think you'll get nervous
as it gets closer?
-I'll definitely get nervous,
but it's excitement, for me,
because, like,
I get to celebrate so many
of the people in my company.
And that, for me,
in a lot of ways,
was way more exciting
than any nomination I got,
because I've been working
with a lot of these people
in the cast for up to 15 years,
and on this show.
And so, getting to
celebrate them,
for me, is going to be,
like, the best part.
-So this is, I mean,
I think this is really --
because I think people
might read about this show
and hear about this show
and think that this was, like,
an overnight success.
-Oh, yeah. So overnight.
-I think that's a really
important thing for people.
-Yeah, George W. Bush had like,
just been re-elected --
re-elected or elected, when
I was first working on this.
-Yeah, so sometimes
I think it's a good --
I don't know, a good reminder
that sometimes you have to
put your nose to the grindstone
and push through a lot of stuff.
-Yeah, I think, like, for me,
the thing that I learned
about making art
in working on this piece is that
it's worth it to take your time.
And that's something I always
tell, like, young students
when I talk to them,
and they're ready
to, like, put their work on an
assembly line and for it to,
you know, chart number one
2 minutes later,
I'm like, "No, I spent 18 years
working on a musical,
so good luck."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think
if you looked back --
I mean, I'm sure you
still have it,
but how massively different
is what it is now
versus the first time
you put it down on the page?
-I mean, it's different
in the sense that,
like, when I started it,
it was a monologue,
and now it's a musical.
But, like, the core ideas
and the feelings that
I was trying to capture
are the same.
So I've been sort of really
trying to track that
all the way from the beginning.
-Well, I'm very excited
that we get to see
a performance tonight.
And thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations on everything.
-Michael R. Jackson, everybody.
"A Strange Loop" is
playing at the Lyceum Theater,
and you can now stream tracks
from the Broadway
cast recording.